to me this is exciting this is like this
is a solution i wish uh
like in april or something like that uh
to
launch like the larger scale
manufacturing deployment of uh tests
doesn't matter what tests they are it's
obviously the capitalist system would
create
cheaper and cheaper tests that that
would be hopefully driving down to one
dollar
so what are we talking about in america
there's i don't know
300 plus a million people
so that means you want to be testing
regularly
right so how many do you think is
possible to manufacture will be the
ultimate goal to manufacture
per month yep so if we want to slow this
virus and actually stop it from
transmitting achieve what i call herd
effects
like vaccine herd immunity herd effects
are when you get that r value below one
through preventing onward transmission
if we want to do that with these tests
we need about 20 million to 40 million
of them every day
uh which is not a lot in the united
states in the united states
so we could do it there's other ways you
can have two people in a household uh
swab each other you know swab
themselves rather and then mix you know
put the swabs into the same tube and
onto one test so you can pool
so you can get a a 2 or 3x
gain in efficiency through pooling in
the household you could do that in
schools or offices too where everyone
just uses a swab you have a
there's two people like i mean even if
it's just standing in line
at a public testing site or something
you know you could just say okay
these two are the last people to test or
swab themselves they go into one
one thing and if it comes back positive
then you just do each person and you
know it's rapid so you can just say to
the people one of you is positive
let's test you again so there's ways to
get the efficiency gains much better but
let's say
i think that that the optimal number
right now that matches sort of what we
can produce
more or less today if we wanted is 20
million a day
right now one company that i don't have
their test here but one company is
already producing five million
tests themselves and shipping them
overseas
it's an american company based in
california called the nova
and they are giving five million tests
to the uk
every day not to the you know
and this is just because there's no the
the federal government hasn't authorized
these tests
so without the support of the the
government so yeah so
essentially if the government just puts
some support behind it
then uh then yeah you can get 20 million
probably easy oh yeah this i mean just
here i have
three different companies these they all
look similar well this one's closed but
these are three different companies
right here this is a fourth
abbott you know this is a fifth this is
a sixth
these two are a little bit different do
you mind if in a little bit would you
take some of these or
yeah let's let's do it we can we can uh
we can absolutely
do that
you